if you're looking for ways to eat well
connect with nature and pay attention to
your body then this video is for you
what are you eating what are you eating
cuz if you're eating Cheetos and
chocolate chip cookies for lunch there's
no way you're gonna feel good not cure
if you slept 12 hours a night before if
you want to boost your immune system you
want to boost your happiness you want to
release serotonin dopamine you want to
release the fear hormone called cortisol
walk in nature this body is essentially
programmed for help every cell in this
body is programmed for health why would
it turn against you because somebody are
not keeping it happy
what's that believe nation it's Evan my
one word is believe and I believe in you
I believe you have an amazing gift
inside you that I want to see explode
out into the world I started to believe
life series to try to tackle every week
a different personal development topic
to help you live your best believe life
so today let's learn five tips to get
healthier and feel better
enjoy
[Music]
tip number one is eat well and exercise
with Joe Rogan and jockle willing
there's a lot of people that are eating
food and then by the end of the day your
body's in a crisis yeah yeah body's just
processing all this [ __ ] yeah and
people asked me that too they go you
know how much you sleep first of all I
could ask all the time so I go to bed
around 11:00 I woke up wake up around
4:30 every day so that's five and a half
hours sometimes I sleep more than that
sometimes I go to bed at 10:00 10:30
11:00 sometimes I stay up later but when
the person says to me oh you know I
can't do that I feel horrible how can I
feel better and my first question is
like what are you eating
what are you eating because if you're
eating Cheetos and chocolate chip
cookies for lunch there's no way you're
gonna feel good knowing cure if you
slept 12 hours a night before yeah
that's a it's a giant factor and if
you're eating a big like bullsh lunch
filled with nonsense like your body's
got to process all that stuff and so the
end of the day yeah you're gonna lose
your willpower
so like when five o'clock six o'clock
rolls around you're gonna be tired but
if you have a healthy lunch and you know
you're properly fueled and then you also
have positive people in your life
everyone's motivated by the end of the
day you're gonna feel good like say if
you're going if you're doing jiu-jitsu
with a bunch of other people that are
doing jiu-jitsu everybody's enjoying it
you're looking forward to that 6:30
class everybody's fired up you get out
of work you're pumped man you what you
doing it when you get out of work you're
fueling up with water you're trying to
get some electrolytes in you because you
know you're gonna get out there on the
mat so you're gonna sweat it out yeah
and the thing you got to do too is when
you get done with work and it was a
grind it you didn't get you get crappy
food and whatever happened happened and
you got yelled at by your boss or
whatever and the real easy decision is
to be like I'm not gonna go train
tonight those the nights you gotta train
cuz that is gonna kick you back on the
track real quick when you get in there
and you see your boys and they're
they're getting ready to tear you up on
the mats and that's gonna get you on
track as opposed to going home and
watching TV which isn't gonna do
anything for you yeah and if there's not
anything whenever the thing is just go
and do it just force yourself to do it
and if you feel like because you ate
lunch then your lunch was you know
filled with [ __ ] well then hey dummy
don't eat lunch tomorrow tomorrow try a
nice salad yeah try a salad with some
salmon and see how you feel then you
okay I feel way better today at 6
o'clock duh yeah now your
decision-making will be better like that
people don't understand how significant
it is like
these little decisions they those are
like that that's the path for the rest
of your existence on earth and if you
decide to go to Cheetos chocolate chip
cookie route you're you're just making a
path you're carving your path through
broken rocks and glass and it's not the
way to go there's no doubt that the the
life change decision isn't one big
decision that you're making all these
little tiny decisions it's you know
having a salad instead of Cheetos that's
that's that's what it is on a daily
basis and if you think about that and
then you just make the right decision on
those little things that's where that's
where the change is tip number two is
connect with nature with Robin Sharma
one of my favorite protocols is the
daily nature walk I love walking in the
woods I often listen to audio books in
the woods
I call it walk reading while walking
reading while walking so I go to this
place it's sort of my creative forest
there's not a lot of people in there and
I walk for one hour I breathe in the air
I look at the lush scenery I listen to a
different audiobook I it's almost like
walking meditation as well sometimes I
don't listen to an audio book and I just
walk and I touch the earth it's almost
like I'm thanking the earth connecting
with the soil yes I'm wearing shoes I
don't want to get too esoteric here but
there's a lot of really good research
saying if you want to boost your immune
system you want to boost your happiness
you want to release serotonin and
dopamine you want to release the fear
hormone called cortisol walk in nature
and so when I walk I connect with nature
tip number three is do the 2-minute
meditation with Tony Robbins so do a
little exercise with me look around I'm
gonna test you find everything you can
see in this room that's brown brown
people but on clothing brown things
anything it's brown and with a tester
you look around look behind you don't
miss anything
close your eyes tell me everything you
just saw that was red
okay open your eyes and look for red
this time fine red you got to find read
anywhere look for red look for red look
for how many found a lot more red this
time and and didn't have it in your head
before raise your hand why cuz we get
what we look for seeking he shall fine
and I'll prove it to you you'll even
find things that aren't there just to
feel successful I'll prove it - you'll
find whatever you looking for how many
saw beige stuff called it brown just to
feel successful when you set your hands
how many saw burgundy called it red just
so you could succeed right so if you
think you're messed up you're gonna find
messed-up stuff in yourself you'll color
it or someone else if you think you're
great gonna fight great things so if you
want to free yourself I'm gonna do a
quick little meditation at the end
you've got to realize that we all suffer
at time said if you want to end
suffering you have to make the most
important decision your life which says
I'm gonna live in a beautiful state
every day no matter what even when it
doesn't go my way even when there's
injustice even when people are unfair
because are people gonna be unjust and
unfair in our lives yes or no and are
you gonna be unjust and unfair at times
without meaning to be yes or no so if
people have to behave a certain way for
us to be happy you're not gonna stay
happy so let's do a two minute
meditation really fast now it's not
meditation like traditional not think of
something how many of you have something
in your life some unfinished business
that's stressful and so you put it off
don't even try to think about it could
be in your business could be in your
personal life could be a relationship
how do you got some at home or at work
that needs to be handled and you put it
off because you're so stressed you got
so much going on who's got something
like this can you think of one
specifically awesome if you don't raise
your hand you lie about other things too
but that's okay we'll talk about later
so here's what I want you to do on a 0
to 10 if you would try to deal with that
right now
honestly 10 is totally stressful zero is
not at all where is it
tell me the number say it out loud how
many got one seven are above of stress
if you focused on it perfect cuz that'll
help you change now I'm gonna give you a
quick technique for two minutes they got
dozens and dozens of these but it'll
work for most of you'll you'll see so
here's what we found research has been
done on how we get stressed and there's
something interesting they discovered
when you're born your heart starts to
beat that's birth that's when you're
alive I don't mean born outside I mean
inside the womb there's no brain when
your heart start
to be what makes your heart beat it has
its own intelligence and it affects your
brain it affects your life it affects
everything when we get in our head we're
dead
we overanalyze we look at things we get
stressed out but in our heart we know
the answer so these researchers did they
were nominated for Nobel Prize because
they found that if you focus on your
heart you put your hands and heart let's
go ahead and do it put your hands on
your heart in fact if you would would
just stand up I think it'll get more of
your body engage if it's sitting so long
shake your body out just for a second
here just for a second if you're at home
do the same all right now put both your
hands on your heart breathe deep inside
your heart
meaning close your eyes if you would and
feel your hands touching your heart feel
the power of your heart and what we're
gonna do is for two minutes we're just
going to get grateful remember earlier I
said you can't the two emotions that
mess this up or anger and fear they mess
up your relationships they mess up your
financial decisions they messed up
career stuff they make some things with
our kids but when you're grateful you
can't be angry when you're grateful you
can't be fearful so we're gonna spend
two minutes of gratitude but we're gonna
focus on a heart because research shows
wherever focus goes energy flows and
when you focus on the heart it changes
literally how your brain functions I
could show you an image of when you're
frustrated and you'll see Iggy's EKGs
that's the electrical power and your
brain and your heart and they're jagged
they're all over we'll probably put it
on the screen when they cut this but if
you breathe in your heart for two
minutes focusing on three things you're
grateful for they literally become in
sync they round and they're won and when
they're won your heart has the answer so
breathe deep in your heart and let's
begin as you breathe deep in your heart
feel the power of your heart feel the
strength of your heart feel the beauty
of your heart what are you proud your
heart has guided you to do with this in
this life or to give or to enjoy or to
love feel the power of your heart it
beats a hundred thousand times a day and
you don't have to do it you have to do
anything
in fact something loved you enough to
give you this heart at the very
beginning you didn't have to earn it did
you you didn't have to prove yourself
you didn't have to prove your worth
something knows your worth and gave you
this gift and called God the universe
whatever you call it but feel that
powerful heart that beats and is always
there for you and has been for decades
and give thanks for it and as you're
breathing in the sense of appreciation
and gratitude we're gonna take about a
minute and a half and focus on three
moments in your life you could feel
deeply grateful for they could be any
three moments it could be from your
childhood it could be from today it
could have been from 10 months ago any
moment that you could step back in that
memory as if you were there and fill up
with a sense of gratitude so right now
I'd like you to think of one of those
moments a magic moment a beautiful
moment from any stage of your life
what's been one of the most beautiful
moments of your life yes so breathe deep
breathe in your heart and step into that
moment that you cherish and fill up with
appreciation with gratitude with joy and
feel yourself going into a beautiful
state as you breathe in your heart and
feel like you're there
think of a second moment now that you
could feed deeply grateful for again it
could've been at any stage it could be
something little or big step into that
moment breathe like you were breathing
then see what you were seeing then hear
and feel what you were hearing and
feeling then and fill up with that
feeling of gratitude go join them and
then finally one more moment that you
can feel grateful for well be a really
beautiful moment of your life you could
relive step into that moment now breathe
deep into it see what you saw hear what
you heard feel what you felt fill up
fill up with love or gratitude or joy
and if you can feel it it feels good
make a sound
don't hesitate like a little kid make a
sound that feels good to you just go
make the sound do it again
and one more time and make it even
louder that's awesome now continue to
feel your heart in this gratitude I bet
there have been times in your life where
things happen for you that you didn't
make happen or like a coincidence you
went to go do something in that somebody
you love or do something to let to a
career or a friendship
what's a coincidence you're grateful for
that led to something beautiful and what
if life was always happening for you not
to you what if you really believed that
even the pain was a gift because it got
you to grow a change or expand what if
everything was happening for you and now
you're in a really beautiful state keep
breathing in your heart and then to
finish this all you've got to do is rip
end a sentence for me keep breathing in
your heart not your head your heart fill
up with that gratitude and then ask
yourself about that thing that used to
stress you a few minutes ago say all I
need to remember Ali to focus on all you
need to do in that situation is what and
trust your heart and knows the answer
that fast
feel your heart all I need to focus on
in that situation all they really need
to do all I need to really appreciate or
feel or experience all I need to focus
on all I need to believe all I need to
do is what and your heart knows the
answer raise your right hand with your
eyes closed if you know the answer if
you know exactly what to do to resolve
the situation raise your right hand nice
and high if you would right now and keep
your hand up as soon as you got it raise
your hand perfect keep your hand up and
then open your eyes and look at the
percentage of people who just in two
minutes have figured out how to solve
what was so stressful if you look around
it's about 90 percent for those of you
that are still there you kind of hang it
on a little bit and for those that are
doing that there are other techniques
but did it reduce it yes even for those
so for you ma'am you didn't which one
didn't raise your hand one of you didn't
raise your head yeah so did it reduce it
for you so where was it and where is it
now I went from a nine to a six so we
could do a second one it was stack it so
what our way to do is this is a way in
two minutes you start to feel stress you
breathe in your heart you focus on what
you're grateful three things and then
you look at the problem and from your
heart you solve it how many got it let
me see Cheyenne somebody got it like
this give ourselves a big has beautiful
tip number four is prioritize sleep with
Brendon Burchard we've known for a very
long time only about 50 years of real
research that if you're not getting
enough sleep your cognitive abilities
throughout the day go down your
creativity goes down your stress goes up
your bad decision-making goes up and
your ability to handle conflict or life
challenges and be resilient and happy
and positive all goes to [ __ ] so what do
you do how do you get more sleep how do
you finally manage this part of your
life because look we all have a lot of
expectations a lot of demands in our
lives and so at some point we start
believing the hype out there that oh hey
you can get by on you know three four
hours of sleep don't worry about it just
sleep a little less get up a little
earlier and we start telling ourselves a
big lie that we can get away with less
sleep even though we have 50 years of
science saying we can't especially today
you know there's this popular myth that
oh you know you can take you know to
sleep for two hours you know rest take a
nap for 30 minutes here and there or
sleep for four hours and nap and
meditate throughout the day to catch up
and the route is we know that's not
possible for the vast majority of people
people say well Brendon the Navy SEALs
can do it I'm like yes but you're not a
Navy SEAL and they hate it and they call
it hell week when they do that ok most
normal average must perform must be
awesome care about your high performance
and have to be smart people throughout
the day really must sleep
seven to eight hours a night and tip
number five the last one before the
bonus is pay attention to your body with
Satguru the thing is we created this
body from inside so the manufacturer of
this body is inside so if you have a
repair job to be done would you like to
go to the manufacturer or to the local
mechanic
if you had access if you had access you
would like to go to the manufacturer if
you lost excess you will go to the local
thinker
to do this and that if there was no
medical science as it is I would say
even half the people would be dead by
now here in this audience yes
because the average life expectancy of
an Indian in 1947 was 28 years
today it is risen to 64 one important
factor is medical science the way it is
so I am NOT trying to belittle or make
fun of medical sciences it is very
significant what has been achieved in
the last 30 to 40 years is phenomenal
the question is just this if you had
access to the source of that which
creates this body definitely every
problem that you generate within the
body could be handled now there are two
kinds of ailments infectious and chronic
infectious ailments happen to us because
of an external invasion from an organism
you must go to the doctor
don't write a meditate on it but 70% of
the ailments on the planet or
self-created I am saying self-created
because it happened from within you so
what is happening from within you can be
very easily fixed from within you what
comes to you from outside you need
outside help for that so you have to
fight an organism then you need medicine
so the rest of the ailments almost 70%
are self created why would your body
work against you this body is
essentially programmed for health every
cell in this body is programmed for
health why would it turn against you
because somewhere you are not keeping it
happy to put it in a very simple
language why would your own family turn
against you somewhere
they're not happy with you isn't it yes
or no they're not happy with you with
something that you're doing so similarly
some cells in the body some parts of
your body are not happy with you for
some reason you must pay a little more
attention there is a way a systematic
way of paying attention to this one
because everything in this body was
created from within when it is so can't
it fix from within so this is not a
miracle I want people to understand this
is not a miracle what is a miracle is
suppose you did not know what is
electricity I came here and I just
pressed that part of the wall and lights
come on who do you think I am suppose
you know a thousand years ago if I had a
cell phone I could just pull out the
cell phone and talk to somebody in
America you would think I'm God isn't it
so what is a miracle is that which you
do not understand that which is not
fitting into your and your logical
perception seems miraculous to you as
your logic evolves so many things which
were miracles 100 years ago or normal
things in our day to day life today
isn't it isn't it so so it is not a
miracle it's just a deeper understanding
of your your of your own the way you are
constructed so this is something that we
need to pay attention
thank you guys so much for watching I
hope you enjoyed I'd love to know what
did you think of this video what was the
biggest takeaway that you're going to
immediately apply to your life somehow
please write down the comments below
I'm curious to find out but also when
you write it down it's much more likely
to stick for yourself as well I also
want to give a quick shout out to be
shimo thank you so much man for picking
up a copy of both of my books taking
that picture and then tweeting it out I
really appreciate the support mate and I
hope you enjoy both of your reads so
thank you guys again for watching I
believe in you I hope you continue to
believe in yourself and whatever you're
one where it is much love I'll see you
soon
[Music]
the first time I went under the Earth's
water is as sharp as needles I saw this
as a big huge sharp diamond at 35 meters
I lost sight because the retina it froze
I couldn't see nothing I couldn't
breathe of course
and then my consciousness succumbed into
a lower consciousness this is survival I
do not fear yet I fear not to live fully
if I left fully and not him to death I'm
living it isn't all about breaking
records
Wims mission is to use his body as a
laboratory to revolutionize our
understanding of physiology in 2011 he
was injected with a bacterial endotoxin
in an experiment that challenged our
understanding of the nervous system
in normal humans the injection should
cause a strong immune response leading
to fever chills and headaches but not
and when it appeared that he was somehow
able to suppress his immune response by
making his body secrete adrenaline
suggesting that his method can allow us
to influence our immune system at will
scientists thought he might just be a
freak of nature so to further prove this
theory they perform the same experiment
on 12 subjects women trained in Poland
and the same thing happened normally
it's very difficult to increase your
adrenaline levels by your own will
adrenaline is released by the autonomic
nervous system and autonomic means that
you cannot voluntarily influence it so
if you walk outside and you are wrapped
on the street you will have a heart rate
of 160 and your blood pressure will be
sky-high within seconds but if I ask you
now to increase your heart rate you
cannot do that you cannot fall entirely
modulate that and with the techniques of
wim HOF we show that he was able to
increase his adrenaline levels to very
high concentrations even higher than
people that Co Bundchen
jumping for the first time there was
something that we didn't think possible
before them the most important work ever
if you had to think of one word that's
most important to you or that sums you
Apple that would be to like a little
beacon they believe nation if you want
to know what the most important one word
is for Tony Robbins Gary Vaynerchuk
Oprah Winfrey will.i.am and Howard
Schultz I have a very special secret
video for you check the description for
details
[Music]